nothing good is born from lies
and greatness is not what you think
[Music]
do you have a film from 1984 that is
your favorite
ghostbusters really why i love that i
don't know i like it was
funny and scary watching this as a child
right it was funny and it scared me
to uh to a healthy extent but not too
much
and it was just um fresh
like when i watched it as a little girl
it was fresh
is there something because i know you
didn't grow up in the 80s but had you
really grown up in the 80s is there
something maybe like you learned through
this film that you think you would have
been completely obsessed with
maybe the shoulder pads like fashion
wise
exactly i got them going on
um i heard and i don't know if this is
true that the first time you watched
this wonder woman 1984 that you cried
that you got very emotional
what was it about it that made you so
emotional because i know we all cry when
we watch it
but what made you emotional first of all
to see the finished
um work we put so much labor into it and
see everything coming together it you
know it got me moved
but i gotta say that the first 10
minutes of the movie where it's not me
playing it's
lily asphall young diana and
and the amazon games really moved me
and and i'm i'm i'm you know i'm all
over the movie and i'm super involved
from the get-go i knew what we were
doing i was there
but all of a sudden watching the olympic
games by i i wasn't gone watching it it
was the 10 year old girl watching
another 10 year old doing the most
amazing things that
i as a person never got to witness yeah
and it got me really moved what do you
think i know this has been a really hard
year for so many people
and so many people just look to you as
this beacon
what do you hope for 2021 assuming and
hoping that we can all
be healthy and move forward what is your
biggest wish honestly
that's that that's my wish if anything
the most important thing is that we have
our health
and and happiness and it's and it's
everything and everything
on top of it is just you know it's just
an extra it's just a gift
have you ever been in love a long long
time ago
you so many times yeah all the time so
my first question to you is do you have
a favorite movie from 1984 that was
released in 1984 and if you don't know
i've got a whole plethora of suggestions
i do i do okay i would say
it's a toss-up between a
beverly hills cup 16
candles and purple rain
wow you've done your homework you've
done your homework i thought you were
going to say ghostbusters
okay sticking with the 80s theme i know
you were a child of the 80s
do you have something that you owned in
the 80s or something that you wanted to
have or thought was really cool
that you definitely think needs to make
a comeback i think
parachute pants make a lot of sense
because they're kind of like the
futuristic
cargo pants yes and if you just make a
cargo pant of like
tight shiny material but you have like
tons of pockets and zippers that don't
have pockets
right i feel like that would make a lot
of sense in these times
um so i read and i hope this is correct
that you said that playing this
character was like playing four
different roles because there's like
four very distinct versions of this
character so of the four
which one was the hardest to sort of get
and which one was the most fun
well definitely cheetah towards the end
of the movie was the most fun um
because she's so bad and i've never
do stuff like that um and the costume
and the makeup and everything it was
just like
yeah it was like the whole dream to be
cheetah
and weirdly i think playing her in the
very
beginning was almost more challenging
because
i didn't i didn't want to make her like
sketchy
comedic but she had to be funny and sad
and
um yeah i had a lot of talks with patti
about how to like find that balance with
her in the beginning
it was amazing it was truly amazing an
amazing amazing role and
it was so it was one of one of the lines
that i love from the movie was
i'm gonna read it so i don't get it
wrong you don't know what you're
learning till you come out the other
side
so now that you're on the other side of
this film and you finished it what is
something that you
learned that is most useful to you in
your life
the feeling that i had after i completed
the movie
um had you know i hadn't seen any
footage or anything i felt i was so
scared to play this part and i was
nervous
about all the physical stuff i knew i
had to do and just
you know there's so many fans out there
of the just the dc world and wonder
woman and i wanted to like do
a good job and i was nervous in the
beginning just to be like totally honest
and then when i
did the role and i felt like i did the
best i could
and i you know it was a really long
shoot
i kind of felt like oh when things scare
you and then you try to do it there's
it's such a good feeling
no matter how it turns out like if
you're yeah
do you have a wish for 2021 assuming and
given that we all sort of can get a
little bit back to normal
yeah i hope it's just nothing like 20
20.
um and i just hope that we all um are
kind to each other
welcome to the future life is good but
it can be better
and why shouldn't it be
all you need is to want it do you have a
movie from
84 that is your favorite super hard to
choose super hard to choose um
maybe beverly hills cop
that's a good one you could do you could
do
like a remake of it i could do a remake
of it i'll play the banana
in the tail pipe i still thought you
were to say the breakfast club but i
think that was 85 wasn't it
it was 85 16 candles was 84.
ah there you go that was it well i
wanted to talk about rain
purple rain purple rain
we could get we could break into song
here if i start singing that would be
punishing
um was there any character that did
sort of like seep into your
consciousness when you were playing max
lord or some sort of an inspiration
you know i came to it with the
preconception that it would definitely
be built on very very specific
references from the 80s i started
talking to patty jenkins uh at the start
uh uh about gordon gekko and wanting to
kind of like oh
yeah you know have have that kind of
calculated cool
and and and and she was like no man this
this
this this guy doesn't have that kind of
polish you know
and and and it's no surprise everything
that she does
has kind of an uncompromising honesty to
it there's such a wholeness to all of
the characters and all of the
performances and
and in the first wonder woman movie i i
i have to say it's probably one of the
first times i ever had like a really
really emotional reaction to an
action sequence you know fame cried
right throughout this time
well you know man it's sort of hi
who did i yeah
sorry did you ugly cry i did i ugly
cried
and and kristen wiig and chris pine are
witnesses because we saw it
you know together safely finally we had
a chance and um
you know with the context of everything
that we've all been through but also the
experience that we all had making the
movie which was a really really
beautiful one
and the message in the movie and also
just the nostalgia of
experiencing entertainment like that
it's just so much delight you know
i felt like i was nine years old going
to see ghostbusters you know
yeah and um and and that really
made me ugly cry in front of them
assuming we all get back to a little bit
more of a normal life in 2021 do you
have a wish for 2021
i do i have a wish that we can all get
together again without being afraid
you know things be safe again so that
families can be together again so that
friends can get together and and i can
go see some live music
i can save today but you can save the
world
congratulations on star wars you are a
real life
female superhero you are a trailblazer
for women and i know this is a personal
story for you so what are you most
excited to bring
to a galaxy far far away something very
similar which is like
i think it's very important to always
not only aim to make a great film for
whatever
franchise or or medium you're aiming for
but also to have a deep connection for
why you're the right director for it
this is just such a special connection
for me to get to make a film about this
and and also make a star wars film which
i've always loved
and so you know i just hope to do this i
hope to do something
totally different than what i did here
but with the same equation
make a great try to make a great film
that you really really believe in
and also bring something to the world
with it that that is
that is personal that you're the right
person to do and
and you know all of those things but i'm
so excited oh we're all so excited even
just your announcement you always make
us cry even your announcement made me
cry i cried
something about wonder woman makes me
weep and it's not tears of sadness or
joy it's just emotional
and pedro and kristen said that you are
very specific in your messages when you
work with
actors it's more about the message and
what you're trying to get across so what
was the most important message for you
with this specific movie with 1984. i
think
it's it's honestly i loved that wonder
woman has her own struggles and all of
the villains have their own struggles
and
when you're making a superhero movie
what's so important is to model
what it is to be a hero in the very
beginning of the movie
wonder woman's mother says to her you
know it's not what you think
you know it isn't being a hero is not
simple it's not just might or speed or
winning
it's a it's more complex than that
through the course of this movie i think
we really experience that it is
that being a hero is being brave and
being willing to
to see the truth and being really to
make difficult
choices and so i love that wonder woman
is such an accessible
superhero that we can do that with her
and hopefully that
that that that teaches a lesson to
a little kid who faces that challenge
themselves and knows that it's not easy
to do
something but has to believe in
themselves you know all of the or
anybody that watches including me
yeah i think um is there a reason you
picked 84 rather than a different year
in the 1980s was there a specific reason
for that yeah 84 was that felt
like the hype to me it felt like the
height of the excess and the opulence
and the fun
and the movies were incredible and and
then you know the stock market started
to go down and we started having more
political problems
in a in a more complex way as the 80s
went on
so it was just like the quintessential
80s and obviously
you know it's so funny everybody asked
me about the book but i i always joke no
no i
was i was about the devil it was about
the um the the album
the last movie no man's land was sort of
the quintessential scene where the
character has this emotional moment that
is the defining moment i think in the
movie
what were you specific in wanting to
have that moment again because i felt
there was that moment but was there a
definite like this is going to be the no
man's land scene for wonder woman 1984.
yeah that's what it was to me a lot of
people didn't realize that
as we were doing it i think her choosing
to be a hero
is what no man's land was all about and
so in this movie we have a very similar
moment where she has to make a decision
and
it's a very different decision with a
very different result
um but i loved i love that we go with
her into
into her life as she makes a choice
you